ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูเอ๋เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะครูเรียม
สวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนค่า
เจอกับครูเรียมกับครูเอ๋นี่ต้องจะต้อง
เป็นเรื่องเกี่ยวกับอะไรคะความเชื่อค่ะ
ครูเอ๋เพื่อเชื่อไหมไม่ต้องเชื่อก็ได้
เชื่อของใครนะเก๋ความเชื่อของ
คนในประเทศไทยนะคะในประเทศไทยนะอาจจะเป็น
ความเชื่อของคนทั้งหมดหรือคนกลุ่มนึงหรือ
จังหวัดนึงหรือภาค 1 ก็ได้นะคะส่วนใหญ่
ที่เราสอนกันมาก็จะเป็นเรื่องเล่าเกี่ยว
กับความเชื่อใช่ไหมคะใช่ค่ะแต่ว่าคลิปนี้
น่ะจะไม่ใช่เรื่องเล่าละ
จะเป็นเป็นขอตัวไป
เชื่ออยู่ได้ยังเป็นความเชื่ออยู่อาจจะ
เป็นความเชื่อของคน
กรุงเทพฯหรือคนต่างจังหวัดหรือคนเมื่อ
ก่อนคนตอนนี้ไม่เชื่อแล้วก็ได้นะคะเดี๋ยว
จะมีมีรูปให้ครูเรียมดู
นะเดี๋ยวคุยขอแช่สักครึ่ง
โอเคมั้ยโอเค
คันคอนิดหน่อยอา
เขาบอกว่าอันนี้เป็นความเชื่อเหมือนกัน
นักเรียน
ถ้าเราอายหรือเจ้า
ครั้งแรก
มีคนคิดถึง
คิวต้องเดี๋ยวได้ 1 ครั้งมีคนคิดถึงครู
เรียมมีคนคิดถึงครูเรียมครูเรียมหรือพูด
ถึงมีคนพูดถึงผู้เรียนเอ้ยคู่จะเป็นยังไง
เลียมมีพูดถึงเรียมก็เลยจามหรือไอออกมา
1 ครั้งค่ะแต่ถ้าเรียมอ่ะอะจาม 2 ครั้ง
[เพลง]
เนี่ยนะรู้จักเลี้ยงไหม
พะยะมากเตรียมที่อยู่ช่องเรียนไทยอ่ะ
มีคนซุบซิบ
[เพลง]
พูดถึงเรียงในซุบซิบนี่คือพูดพูดกัน
เรื่องดีหรือไม่ดีเอออ่ะสุข 10 นิ่มอาจจะ
ดี 50% ไม่ดี 50%
แต่ถ้าคุณเรียมจาม 3 ครั้ง
โรงพยาบาลค่ะ
อันนี้ไม่สบายและหรือไม่ก็มายคงไม่สว่าง
แล้วเดี๋ยวกูเอกจะพาไปดูอย่างอื่นอีกนะคะ
นักเรียนนี่
เห็นไหมคุยกันทำครูใหญ่ๆก่อนกำลังมาห้อง
มาละมาละมาแล้ว
คุณเรียมในภาพนี้คุณเรียนเห็นใช่ไหมคะมือ
โอเคขยายให้เต็มๆเห็นชัดไหมคะเห็นชาร์จ
ค่ะกูเองเป็นมืดสีดำแล้วก็นกสวยใช่นกสวย
นะหน้าเหมือนกับเหมือนแมว
นกตัวนี้สวยๆแต่คนไม่ชอบ
มันชื่อว่านกแสก
เรียนรู้ไหมทำไมคนไม่ชอบ
เรียกคิดว่าเสียงร้องของนกแสบมันน่ากลัว
มันจะร้องเสือ
ร้องเลขรหัสสร้าง
มันร้องแสกอะไรชื่อนกฝกใช่ไหม
นกตัวนี้ค่ะนักเรียนคะครูเรียมค่ะนกแสก
เนี่ยเรามีความเชื่อว่า
ถ้าตอนกลางคืนใช่ไหมคะอ่ะกูเองวัดบ้าน
บ้างสิขาวมีบ้านอยู่ตรงนี้
แล้วก็
ตรงหน้าเป็นหลังคาบ้านนะคะหลังคาบ้านท่า
นกแสกน่ะมาแล้วก็เกาะ
ก็ที่หลังคาบ้าน
ไปบ้านไม่เหมือน
ค่ะนกมาที่นี่นะฮะ
จะวัด
นะ
ครับเกาะที่นี่
เกาะหลังคาบ้านแล้วก็ร้องแซบสาปรัก
งูจะทำให้คนที่อยู่ในบ้านนอนไม่หลับใช่
ไหมคะตัวเองเขาก็เลยไม่ชอบไม่ใช่ค่ะนอน
ไม่หลับด้วยแต่ว่าเขามีความเชื่อว่าถ้า
เกิดนกแสกเกาะหลังคาบ้านเนี่ยอ่ะจะมีคน
เนี่ย
ตายขายใน 3 ถึง 7 วัน
หรือบางทีคนคนที่เรารักคือถ้ามีคนไม่สบาย
อยู่ในบ้านก็เดี๋ยวเขาก็จะตาย 1 ออหรือ
ว่าว่ามีเป็นโชคไม่ดี
ปากถ้าเกิดมีนกมาก่อนคนในบ้านเนี่ยจะโชค
ไม่ดีจะไม่สบายจะตายหรือมังทีเราไม่ตาย
แต่ว่าอาจจะเป็นคนที่เรารัก
เสียชีวิต
นี้นะคะเขามีความเชื่อแบบนั้น
กูอีกนกจากขึ้นมากอบมาให้กูอีก 1 ครั้ง
เราเกิดอะไรขึ้นไหมคะอ้าอันนั้นเด็กๆไง
เลยจำไม่ได้ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นจำได้แค่ว่าพอ
ได้ยินเสียงเนาะและ
พ่อกับแม่ก็ออกมาแล้วก็ไล่รถตกใจใหญ่เลย
แล้ววันรุ่งขึ้นก็ไปหาพระ
จากนั้นก็ไม่รู้ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้นอีกหรือ
เปล่านะคะก็
พ่อกับแม่ตัวเองได้เล่าให้ฟังไหมไม่ได้
เล่าให้ฟังเพราะว่าคุณเอ๋ไปกลับไปหาไปที่
บ้านแล้วก็กลับมากรุงเทพฯเพราะครูเองไม่
ได้อยู่กับพ่อแม่เนาะอยู่กับป้าก็ไปที่
บ้านเอาประมาณ 7 วันแล้วก็เจอนกแสกเราก็
กลับกรุงเทพฯก็ไม่รู้ว่าต่อจากนั้นเกิด
อะไรขึ้น
เลยแต่ไม่รู้เหมือนกันแต่ว่าเกิดอะไรขึ้น
แต่นกแสกเกาะหลังคาบ้านและมีน้ำเสียงน่า
กลัวจริงๆเรียมให้เวลากลางคืนมืดแล้ว
เสียงแทรกมันขนลุกอ่ะ
คนลูกการ์ตูนจริงๆสวยเนาะน่ารักแถวบ้าน
ครูเรียมชื่อร้านอะไรนะเรียบไม่เคยเห็น
แถวบ้านเรียนน่ะไม่เคยเห็นนกแสกแต่แต่เคย
ได้ยินใช่ไหมคะความเชื่อนี้เคยได้ยินค่ะ
ว่าถ้าเกิดแบบนกแสกมะเกาะที่หลังขาบานไม่
ดีอือเนาะจริงไม่จริงเราไม่ทราบนะคะนัก
เรียนนะคะแหลมหลายคนก็เชื่อแบบนี้ต่อไปมา
ดูก่อนเสื้อต่อไปดีกว่า
น่ารัก
กูอูเอเลี้ยงไหมคะเลี้ยงไว้ที่บ้านไหม
ไม่ได้เลี้ยงค่ะแต่มี
ก็คือคือบ้านที่ชลบุรีก็มีเยอะบ้านที่
กรุงเทพฯนะที่คอนโดนะมีนะครูเรียมแล้วกู
เอกพยายามที่จะเอาออกไปสามีชอบสามีบอกว่า
เป็นเพื่อนกัน
ฉันพี่คุยชอบมากอ่ะตัวนี้เรียกว่าอะไรนะ
คะครูเรียมนี้ว่าจิ้งจกจิ้งจกนะคะจิ้งจก
เนี่ยเกาะที่บ้านคือถามว่าครูเอกชอบไหมก็
น่ารักแต่ไม่ได้อยากที่อยู่ในบ้านเพราะ
จิ้งจกชอบขี้
จิ้งจกจะมีขี้ใช่ไหมคะแล้วขี้เขาเนี่ย
เป็นสีขาวกับสีดำ
ใช่
มีปีขาวแล้วก็สีดำตรงเนี้ยโอ้โห
ครูเอ๋ทำให้เตรียมอยากกลับไปดูช่องน่ะ
National  Geographic ร้านอาหารฟิล์มก็
อยากรู้ว่าทำไมขี้ติ้งจบมีสีขาวกับสีดำ
หน้าสื่อสงสัยเหมือนกันใช่มั้ยใช่ไหมกู
เลี้ยงเห็นใช่ไหมเป็นสีขาวสีดำนะคะอาคี
สามีคู๋เนี่ยชอบจิ้งจกเพราะว่าเขาบอกว่า
เวลามียุง
ยุง
ที่บ้านบัญชีมียุงจิ้งจอกดบจะกินอยู่อ๋อ
จะกินแมลงถ้าเกิดมีจิ้งจกก็ไม่มีแมลงและ
ครูเอ๋ต้องมานั่งเช็ดขี้วันหน้าเขาไม่
ได้ทำดิฉันทำนะคะแล้วมีนะชอบออกลูกชอบออก
ลูกในห้องน้ำ
ไอ้มีใครคือข้างบนห้องน้ำมันจะมีรูอยู่
อ่ะค่ะแล้วเขาเข้าไปข้างในแล้วบางทีลูกก็
วิ่งลงมาคือคือ
กูเอกก็ยังมีความเชื่อเกี่ยวกับจิ้งจก
อยู่ผลงานเขาเรียกว่า 40  60 และกัน
20 กับ 60 คือ 40% เนี่ยยังเชื่อ 60%
อ่ะไม่เชื่อไม่เชื่อฮ่าๆ
ก่อนจะไปแล้วความเชื่อเกี่ยวกับจิ้งจก
ครั้งจิ้งจกเนี่ยทำมันหลุดนะมันยังดิ้น
ได้
ตัวเองเห็นแล้วรู้สึกยังไง
จับจิ้งจกได้นะคะแต่กลัวหายจึงจบ
เอกจะ
จับได้ไม่เป็นไรไม่ๆไม่ได้กลัวจิ้งจกและ
ถ้าหายจริงจบหลุดนะเนี่ยกลัว
อาหารปิ้งจบมันจะดิ้งดินๆกลัวกลัวหาง
จิ้งจกนะคะอ่าที่นี้เนี่ยจิ้งจกเนี่ยค่ะ
เขามีความเชื่อโคเรียมความเชื่อว่ายังไง
อ่ะเราชื่อว่าถ้าอยู่ที่บ้านเหรียญ
ร 9 อันนี้กูเรียนอยู่บ้านแล้วกูเรียนจะ
ออกไปข้างนอกอ่ะขอบคุณเรียมเดินมาถึง
ประตู
แล้วคิดจะเปิดประตูบ้านแล้วมีจิ้งจก
จิ้งจกร้องทัก
ดูไหมเขาห้ามออกจากบ้านอ้าว
ทำไมเค้าเอ๋เตรียมต้องออกจากบ้านไปทำงาน
ว่าจะมีอุบัติเหตุจะมีอันตราย
จิ้งจกบอกว่าเดี๋ยวไม่ไปเลี้ยงไม่ไป
อันตรายอันตราย
หัวเราะเสื้อไว้
เดี๋ยว
คือปกติจิ้งจกเขาจะร้องตอนกลางคืนมืดเนาะ
เมื่อเช้าก็ไม่ค่อยจะร้องไง
หนาวเนี่ย
อันเนี้ยข้ามไปนะนี่ได้จริงๆก็ทุกเวลา
แหละไอ้โจ๊กร้องเปิดเวลาเปิดประตูอ่ะอ่ะ
แต่ถ้าเราอยู่บ้านแล้วแล้วเรายังไม่เปิด
ประตูออกไปเขาเขาร้องไม่เป็นไรนะคะแต่
เมื่อไหร่จะเปิดจะจะนะคะจะคือยังไม่เปิด
เดินๆนะจะจับประตูจะเปิด
โอเคปิดโทรศัพท์เจ้านายวันนี้ออกจากบ้าน
ไม่ได้
ทำไมจิ้งจกร้องไม่ให้ออกไป
มั้ยอ๋อแล้วคืออีกแล้วบอกเจ้านายว่าตัว
เองเชื่อว่าถ้าเกิดออกไปเนี่ยโชคไม่ดีใช่
ไหมไม่อาจจะมีรถชนไม่สบายเจ้านายก็จะบอก
ว่าโอเคงั้นก็ไม่ต้องมาเลยใช่ก็หยุดเลย
พุ่งพรุ่งนี้ต้องไปทำงานไหมคะขอให้บอก
พรุ่งนี้ก็ไม่ต้องมา
ต้องมาเรื่องนี้ก็ไม่ต้อง
ซื้อไหมตอนกูอ่ะเด็กๆที่เป็นนักเรียนอ่ะ
แล้วกูเองอยู่กับไม่ได้อยู่กับคุณพ่อคุณ
แม่อยู่กับป้า
เชื่อมากวันไหนจะไปข้างนอกตึกป้าไม่ได้ทำ
งานข้างนอกวันไหนอยากจะออกไปข้างนอกและ
จิ้งจกป้าเปลี่ยนเสื้อผ้าอยู่บ้านเลยไม่
ไป
ปลาน่าจะเชื่อ
100% ว่าจิงจกไม่ได้ร้องทุกวันไงครู
เรียม
เอกเคยเจอแบบนี้แล้วจะไปโรงเรียนนะจิ้งจก
เก๋วันนี้ไม่ต้องไปโรงเรียนเดี๋ยวบอกโรง
เรียนว่าไม่สบาย
ไม่ได้
ไม่ได้ป่ะต้องฟัง
และทำไมเขาถึงที่ท่อง
เที่ยวง่วงมันจะแบบไม่ดีเวลากระจกหรอก
เค้าว่ากันว่าเคยมีไงกรณีที่อ่ะสามีภรรยา
หรือลูกเนี่ยอาจกำลังจะเดินออกจากบ้านและ
จิ้งจกร้องนั่งร้องทักแต่คนไม่เชื่อไป
แล้วก็อาจจะขับมอเตอร์ไซค์แล้วมี
อุบัติเหตุเขาก็เล่าต่อๆกันมาว่าจึงจบ
ร้องทักเนี่ยให้เชื่อนะแต่ที่ร้องทักหรือ
ยังยังไม่เท่าไหร่นะแต่ถ้าเปิดประตูบ้าน
ออกมาแล้วจิ้งจกตกลงมารถตาย
ตบมานะเราก็ตายอันนี้นี่ร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์
ห้ามออกเลยครูเอ๋อาจจะเป็นที่ประตูบ้าน
เราก็ได้นะประตูบ้านมากกว่าอันนี้เห็น
อยู่ใช่ไหมค่ะเรียนต้องเห็นนะคะขอตัดที่
เรียว
เอาเส้นเล็กเกินไปไหมอันนี้ประตูบ้างเรา
ตอนที่เราปิดประตูบ้านน่ะค่ะเขาอยู่ตรง
นี้
ยิ่งจบอยู่ตรงนี้แล้วมันมีหนีบจิ้งจกขอ
เวลาเราเปิดออกมา
จิ้งจกก็เลยร่วงลงมาตายหมอจะมาถ้าโดนนี่
มันก็แบนสิคะ Man ตายใช่ไหม
กูเอกเคยเจอแบบนี้นะกูเรียมคือเปิดประตู
ปากจิ้งจกตกลงมาตายแบบไม่แบนอ่ะ
ดิ้นไหมกับพี่จะไม่ได้นะนายเลยอ่ะค่ะอ้าว
คือคือไม่รู้อยู่ที่ไหนไม่ได้อยู่ที่
ประตูด้วยนะอาจจะอยู่ข้างนอกแล้วตกลงมา
เลยอ่ะแล้วก็ตายไปหรือไม่ไป
แล้วผู้เอกออกจากบ้านไหมคะวันนั้น 40
เปอร์เซ็นต์ไงเพื่อ
ก็ไม่ได้อย่ากรุงเทพฯต้องทำงานตัวเอกก็
อ้อจิ้งจกเป็นอะไรแต่เอ็มไม่ได้ไม่ได้บีบ
ไม่โดนเขานะก็ก่อนไปทำงานก็มีอาหารแล้วก็
ถวายพระทำบุญก่อนวันนี้จริงจบๆเอาบุญให้
จบนะไม่โกรธกันนะ
ไปค่ะคือครูเอกก็ไม่รู้ว่าจริงหรือไม่
จริงนะคะก็มีคนหลายคนเขาเชื่อเรื่องนี้นะ
คะแต่กูเองเจอจิ้งจกตกมาตายหลายรอบละแล้ว
ก็ไอ้ออกไปแต่ก็ไม่ได้จำว่ามีอุบัติเหตุ
มีไม่สบายมีอะไรหรือเปล่าเพราะว่ารู้สึก
ว่าเฮ้ยถ้าเชื่อมากเราก็จะกลัวมากให้แล้ว
ที่บ้านจิ้งจกเยอะขนาดเนี้ย
จิ้งจกเยอะขนาดเนี้ยมันต้องมีตายอยู่แล้ว
ไงถ้าเราไม่อยากจะมีความเชื่อนี้เราต้อง
เอาจิ้งจกออกไปให้หมด
ใช่มั้ย
ใช่ค่ะเรียมที่บ้านมีจิ้งจกเสือ
ร้อง Heart
[เพลง]
เรียงกำลังหาใส่ชาร์จอยู่อ๋อแบตหมดเลย
อยู่ดีๆก็เฮ้ยแบบจมูก
มาเรื่องของคนบ้างค่ะครูเรียมนี่หะตาปาย
เรื่องของคนเรื่องของหู
หนูทำไมคะพี่เอ๋าเขาบอกว่าถ้าคนมีตรงนี้
เรียกว่าติ่งหูติ่งหูเนี่ยยาวพูดยาวไหม
ไม่นะแบบของเดียวไม่ยาวฉันขอดูใกล้ๆรึยัง
อ่าครูเรียม
ยาวบางคนบางคนเขาไม่มีค่ะมีแค่นี้
ของคู่เดิมยาวนั้นอ่ะอ๋อกูตั้งเส้นหนึ่ง
กูเรียมอาจจะไม่ดีค่ะคุณเอ๋
อุ้ยมีชีวิตนานๆ
โชคจริงๆถ้าเกิดว่ายาวเนี่ยกูเริ่มจะมี
ชีวิตนั้นๆ 100 ปี
เฮ้ยแต่แต่ว่าถ้ายาวแล้วก็หนา
หนานะฮะโออันนี้จะโชคดี
โชคดีแบบมีตำแหน่งสูงๆเป็นเจ้าของบริษัท
นะคู๋ไม่หนากูเรียนครูเอ๋ไปคุยดึงบ่อยๆนะ
อายุยืน
100 ปี
สามร้อยปีใช่ไหมตอนเด็กๆนอนเด็กๆตอนโต
ขึ้นขึ้นไปไม่ต้องยืน
ตอนเด็กๆเพลงหูยาวอายุยืนไปดึงของตัวเอง
ทุกวันยาวไหมยาวแบบนึงอย่าไว้เป็นน้าอ้วน
เนี่ยมันทำไม่ได้ไงอ่ะ
ตัวเราเองไม่น่าไปหานักเรียนโชว์หูกันเลย
ฮะถ้านักเรียนหนานะคะอันเนี้ยแล้วกูเอ๋
สังเกตนะเก๋ดูดูที่อะไรนะเวลาที่ญี่ปุ่น
นัดนัดการเมืองญี่ปุ่นเข้ามาประชุมคุยกัน
นะคุ่กับดูติ่งหูเป็นกูใหญ่
ฉีดซิลิโคนหรือเปล่า
ธรรมชาติหรือนักธุรกิจไทยอ่ะที่ประเทศไทย
อ่ะครูเรียมลองดูนักธุรกิจอ่ะติ่งหูก็แจก
ใหญ่หนา
มี
งอแบบผู้เรียนอย่างนี้ค่ะของกูเองไม่นอน
เห็นไหมกูอีกแบรนด์ไปเลยอย่างนี้บางทีมอง
แล้วมันไม่เห็นไม่มีหูของกูเรียนเนี่ยตัว
นี้จะนอนขึ้นใช่ป่ะเออเอาตรงนี้ล่ะได้
แล้วนะธาตุขนานไอ้โอ๋สมบูรณ์มีเงินเยอะ
มากๆใช่ไหมถ้าเกิดเปิดสัตว์บ๊าย
ไปคดูซิลิโคนเข้าไปเฮ้ยไม่ได้ฉีดไม่ได้
ต้องธรรมชาติมันอะไรนะเอ่อหน้าผากหน้าผาก
กว้างวัดหน้าผากกว้างน่ะใช่ไหมกว้างเนี่ย
ดีบางคนก็ได้เป็นดึงผมออก
ไม่ได้ต้องเป็นธรรมชาติจริงๆ
อ่ะต่อไปต่อไป
ความเชื่อต่อไปนะคะ
เกี่ยวกับมามั้ยมามั้ยตาเหรอในค่ะปลา
ตานะผู้เรียนรู้จักอะไรนะเขม่นตาไหม
คำเห็น
ค่ะหยิบก็หยิบตามันอย่างนี้อิบตาขยิบตา
กระตุกรู้จักตากระตุกนั่นแหละค่ะเขม่นตา
เพราะเขมรสามารถเอ๋เลขค่ะเหม็นนะ
ถ้า
ภาษาปกติให้กระตุกใช่ไหมกระตุกหรอกปลา
เนี่ยมันเกิดๆๆๆๆๆ
จริงๆค่ะไวตามินใช่
จิ้มคิดว่านอนน่ะนอนน้อยๆตาก็จะกระตุก
แต่เราไม่ได้กระตุกบ่อยๆบางคนอาจถ้า
ปัจจุบันหมอก็บอกว่าเราขาดไวตามินอะไรสัก
อย่างหนึ่งนะคะเซลล์ประสาทมีปัญหาแต่ว่า
สมัยโบราณเขาเชื่อว่าถ้าเขม่นตาหรือว่าตา
กระตุกเนี่ย
ขวาต้องรู้ว่าขวาหรือซ้าย 5 ป่าข้างขวา
กระตุกฟ้าขวาเนี่ยจะเป็นเรื่องไม่ดี
แล้วถ้าเป็นตาซ้ายเหรอลาซ้ายจะเดินดี
เขาก็บอกว่าขวาร้านซ้าย
อ่า
อันนี้เวลาตากระตุกหรอกแกมาซ้ายนะ
คือจะไม่กระตุกสองข้างนะจะกระตุกหนึ่ง
ข้างเท่านั้นน้ำ
จึงไม่จริงไม่ใช่นักเรียนต้องลองสังเกตุ
นะคะถ้าเมื่อไหร่ที่นักเรียนในปากกระตุก
ว่าขวาอ๋อไม่ดิ of ซ้ายดีแล้วก็ดูว่าจริง
ไหมนะคะ
อ้าต่อไปต่อไปอันไหนดีอ่ะเอาสัตว์ EP เรา
มีความเชื่อเยอะมากมายก็มีเยอะมากจริงๆมี
เป็นร้อยความเชื่อนะคะมีเป็นร้อยๆความ
ซื้ออ่ะเอาจะติดตัวนึงแล้วกันตัวนี้
อะไรคะคุณผึ้งค่ะ
วันนี้เป็นรังผึ้ง
มะกอกที่บ้าน
ถ้าเขาเริ่มเกาะเรียมปเต็มที่ที่รักพึ่ง
มาเริ่มเกาะตัว 2 ตัวใช่ไหมคะซึ่งหาค่า
เรากลัวเราต้องไล่ไปใช่ไหมใช่
แต่คนไทยก็มีความเชื่อถ้าผึ้งมาเกาะที่
บ้านไม่ให้ไล่ไป
ต่อยนะคะคะเองอุ้ยถ้าเราไม่ไปโดนเขาเขาก็
ไม่ต่อยเราไงเขาบอกว่าโชคดี
จริงหรอไม่รู้กี่บ้านก็มีเหมือน
เวลาเขาลังใหญ่ๆแล้วเขาก็จะมีตัวพึ่ง
เยอะๆแต่ว่าพอเขาโตโตเดี๋ยวเขาก็ไปแล้ว
เขาก็ทิ้งเลยหลังไว้เราอ๋อเมื่อนะก็ไม่
ได้ทิ้งเอาไว้แล้วนะกลับมาได้น้ำหวานได้
อะไรมาหาเขาโตลูกเขาโตหมดเค้าก็ทิ้งก็ไป
เอาไปหาที่ใหม่แต่ที่บ้านครูเอกเคยนี้นะ
ในตู้เสื้อผ้าเนยตู้เก็บเสื้อผ้าน่ะเป็น
ตู้เป็น
เอาแบบนี้
สีดำดีกว่า
ตู้เสื้อผ้าลาก็ชั้นล่างอ่ะชั้นล่างตรง
เนี้ยเปิดออกมาตัวนัดจะอยู่ข้างในมามา
อยู่ประมาณ 3-4 เดือนแล้วก็ไปร่างใหญ่ไหม
คะพี่เอ๋เต็มเลยค่ะเต็มตู้เลยค่ะแล้วก็คบ
อ่ะแล้วไปไปเสร็จเพราะถึงเวลาก็มาอีกจะ
เป็นอยู่เงี้ยประมาณ 3-4 ปี
พ่อก็ไม่ให้ไร่เอกก็ชอบไปเปิดดูอาจารย์ไป
แล้วเอาน้ำผึ้ง
กินน้ำผึ้งด้วยนายอาจารย์ไปลองไว้ให้น้ำ
พึ่งไหลนะวิธี
เด็กๆไงเด็กไม่ดีส่วนบางทีก็เอาไม้ไป
เขี่ยให้น้ำพึ่งไหลคุณก็บินออกมาแล้วก็
วิ่งหนี
สนค่ะภาษาไทยเลยว่าสดเราเข้าเชื่อว่าอะไร
คะพี่เอกทำไมไม่ใช่ไล่เอาเท่าไหร่ไปโชคช
เมื่อกี้ก็ไปค่ะอันนี้เพิ่งมาอยู่น่ะเป็น
เอาโชคเอารากมาให้โชคดีโชคดีลาภก็คืออะไร
ที่เราไม่ต้องเหนื่อยแล้วเราก็ได้มาใช่
ไหมคะอันนี้ก็เล่นลาภนะคะก็ถ้ามีผึ้งมาก็
โชคดีค่ะปล่อยเขา
กลัว
จะเป็นความเชื่อถ้าเราไม่เชื่อเราก็เชิญ
ก็ออกไปก็อะไรนะมีควันมีควันไฟอะไรเดี๋ยว
เขาก็ออกไปอ๋อ
[เพลง]
สุดท้ายแล้วกันยังมีเวลาอีกนิดนึงๆๆ
โอเคเอาเงินที่นอนบ้างดีกว่ากูเองมีเยอะ
ไม่ต้องรู้ว่า
ที่นอนนี่นี่
อ่า
เวลานอนอันนี้เป็นทิศเหนือนะคะเราจะมี
แบ่งถ้าคลิปมีเหนือ
ตะวันออก
ใต้ตะวันตกค่ะเรามีความเชื่อว่าถ้าเรานอน
น่ะ
ห้ามเอาหัวไปทางทิศนินอนแบบนี่
ห้ามเอาหัวไปทิศตะวันตกจะไม่ดีค่ะ
นี่เอาไปทางทิศตะวันออกแบบได้ๆได้คิด
เหนือได้ที่ตะวันตกไม่ได้เพราะว่าเป็น
อะไรเป็นที่ของคนที่เสียชีวิต
เวลาที่คนตายแล้วเนี่ยเขาจะอ่ะให้นอนไป
ทางเอาหัวไปทางทิศตะวันตกนะคะฉะนั้นเนี่ย
คนปกติเราก็ไม่นอนจ้านอนเอาหัวไปทิศตะวัน
ตกจะโชคไม่ดีนอนฝันไม่ดี
ก็อันตรายเราก็จะเหนื่อย
เชื่อไหมอันนี้ก็เรียงเชื่อมั้ย
เตรียมเต็มเชื่อให้เพราะว่าเพลงนอนกู
เลี้ยงหัวไปทิศไหนคะเตียงนอนเต็มหัวไปทาง
ทิศตะวันออกทิศตะวันออกนะเพราะว่าเชื่อ
ไม่ไปทิศตะวันตกใช่มั้ยใช่เพราะว่าแม่ก็
จะพูดห้ามหันหัวไปทางทิศตะวันตกเตรียมก็
เลยแบบจำจำจำๆมาตั้งแต่เด็กแล้วก็โตขึ้น
โตขึ้นก็เลยห้ามหันหัวไปทิศตะวันตก
แล้วเวลาจะนอนเวลาไปไปบ้านเพื่อนก็จะถาม
เพื่อนอันนี้ที่อายอันนี้ที่ตะวันตกใช่
มั้ยเรียนจะได้ไม่นอนเอาหัวไปทางทิศตะวัน
ตกฮ่าๆกูเอกก็เมื่อก่อนกูเอกก็เชื่ออัน
นี้คุยเชื่อ 80% นอ่ะนะ 80% แต่ที่บ้านมา
นี่ล่ะค่ะทิศบ้านแม่เนี่ยห้องครูเอ๋น่ะ
อยู่ทางทิศตะวันตกและแม่ทำทำอะไรทำศาลพระ
ภูมิตรงนี้ถ้ากูเอาหัวไปทิศตะวันออก
ป่าวไปศาลพระภูมิไม่ได้เหนหัวไปทางทิศใต้
โอเคเอกก็มองเห็นศาลพระภูมินอนไปดูศาลพระ
ภูมิไม่ได้กูเอจะนอนเอาสุดท้ายก็คือฆ่า
กันต้องนอนเอาหัวไปทิศตะวันตก
อันนี้ก็ไม่ดีใช่ไหมคะสุดท้ายคือต้องเอา
หัวไปทางทิศเหนือ
ทิศเหนือแบบนี้
แล้วก็ปิดผ้าม่านปิดร้อยเปอร์เซ็นต์
ไม่ให้เห็นศาลพระภูมิถ้าเราเป็นเวลานอน
ลืมตาเห็นศาลพระภูมิไม่ต้องหรอตัวเองไม่
แบบสวัสดีค่ะอะไรลืมตาขึ้นมาก็สวัสดีค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเกิดมีคนสวัสดีด้วย
แต่ว่าที่กรุงเทพฯอ่ะกูเรียมห้องนอนตัว
เองนะคือหัวทิศตะวันตกค่ะ
นัดเตียงนอนเนี่ยขยับไม่ได้
คือทุกวันนี้ก็คือท่านอนแบบนี้
หมอนก็ร่วมที่นี่ใช่ไหมคะล่าสุดท้ายตอน
แรกที่นอนหัวไปทิศตะวันตกทุกวันแต่ทุก
อย่างก็โอเคใช่ไหมคะเอกพระเอกหลับฝันร้าย
นะ
คุยหลับไม่สบายกูเอกก็จะมันทีก็นอนแล้วก็
นอนขวาง
นอนขวางเตียง 1 เตียงจะนอนอย่างนี้เลย
นอนหลับอ่ะแน่
นอนแบบนี้ค่ะๆ
หลับไปโอเค 3 ชั่วโมงวันที่ 2 ชั่วโมง
แล้วก็ตื่นมาแล้วก็คอสามีมานอนใช่มั้ย
สามีกลับมานอนกูเอกก็ไปนอนโซฟา
เอาหัวไมค์คู่เอกเชื่อไหมคะหลังนี้ไม่น่า
จะมีไม่เชื่อเอกเอาเอาหัวไปทางทิศตะวัน
ออกสามีกูเองไม่เชื่อเรื่องนี้นะคะแบบกู
อีกรู้สึกเองว่าหัวไปทิศตะวันตกนอนแล้ว
ไม่สบาย
สึกนอนแล้วป่ะหลับไม่สบายแต่ถ้าไปทางทิศ
นี้หรือมาทางทิศนี้นะนอนหลับสบายนะคะ
เป็นความเชื่อเนาะใช่นักเรียนอาจจะตกใจ
ถ้วนไหมวอนหันหัวไปทางไหนอ่ะ
ตัวจริงไม่จริงไม่รู้นักเรียนต้องทดลองดู
นะฮะดูว่าตอนนี้อยู่ทิศไหนหัวทิศเหนือทิศ
ตะวันออกตะวันตกหรือทิศใต้ถ้าไม่รู้ว่า
จริงไม่จริงนักเรียนก็ลองเอาหัวไปทางทิศ
ตะวันตก
ครับทิศตะวันตกแล้วไม่ดีก็ขอจริงมาหา
เวลาหมดแล้วคุณเอ๋ค่ะหมดแล้วก็ต้องไปแล้ว
นะคะใช่ฮะต้องไปแล้วต้องเจอกันในคลิปหน้า
น่ะค่ะกูเองวันนี้ต้องลาไปก่อนค่ะนัก
เรียนสวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะค่ะยิ้มอายๆ